Es gibt Kräfte, die versuchen,
einen Keil zu treiben
zwischen eine
vermeintliche politische Elite
und die breite Bevölkerung.
Das ist etwas, das es in der Schweiz
eigentlich nicht gibt.
(Brenzikofer) Man nimmt es
für zu selbstverständlich.
Ich wünsche mir,
wir hätten einen höheren Anteil
an wählenden und stimmenden Personen
in der Schweiz.
Denn es ist ein riesiges Privileg,
das wir haben.
Es zeichnet sich dadurch aus,
dass man sich meist
mit sehr wenigen Vorurteilen trifft.
Dass man mit jedem reden und
ein gemeinsames Ziel verfolgen kann.
Es ist einzigartig. Das gilt es
bis zum Letzten zu verteidigen.
Deshalb versuche ich,
die Menschen zu motivieren,
an politischen Abstimmungen
und Wahlen teilzunehmen.
Mir gefällt vieles nicht von dem,
was im Bundeshaus entschieden wird.
Ich möchte nicht nur motzen, sondern
auch zu Veränderungen beitragen.
Meine Stimme
ist z.B. ein Teil davon.
* Beschwingte Bläserklänge *
Vor Gianna Luzio liegt ein Jahr, das
sie so schnell nicht vergessen wird.
Heute, auf den Tag genau
ein Jahr vor den Wahlen,
hat sie ihren ersten Aufritt
als neue Generalsekretärin der CVP.
Im Wahlkampf wird Luzio
eine zentrale Rolle spielen.
Wir kommen zur Begrüssung
unserer neuen Generalsekretärin,
Gianna Luzio-Wieser. Sie ist in
einer CVP-Familie aufgewachsen.
Das war die Grundvoraussetzung
dafür, eingeladen zu werden.
Sie hat sich auch
politisch für die CVP engagiert.
Herzlich willkommen, Gianna.
Wir freuen uns auf gute Zusammen-
arbeit. Ich gebe dir gerne das Wort.
Stima signur president,
stimada cussegliera federala,
stima chancelier federal,
ich hätte nicht
davon zu träumen gewagt,
dass ich eines Tages, das heisst
heute und hier, vor Ihnen stehe,
vor Ihnen stehen darf
als Ihre Generalsekretärin.
Wir haben Grosses vor.
In zwölf Monaten sind Wahlen,
in wenigen Wochen
eine Bundesratswahl.
Wir starten heute, lancieren heute
eine Volksinitiative.
Und auch mit der Wahlkampagne
sind wir schon unterwegs.
Ich freue mich unglaublich,
gemeinsam mit Ihnen
diese Aufgaben anzupacken
und die Schweiz
gemeinsam voranzubringen.
In cordial grazia fitg.
Ich war davor sehr nervös.
Nun bin ich sehr zufrieden.
Es hat sich gut angefühlt.
Es hat Spass gemacht. Ich glaube,
es war ein guter Startschuss.
Jetzt muss sich die CVP nur noch
Gehör bei den Wählern verschaffen.
Gleich
nach der Delegiertenversammlung
beginnt für Gianna Luzio
der Wahlkampf auf der Strasse.
Mit einer Kostenbremse
für das Gesundheitswesen
gehen die Christdemokraten
auf Wählerjagd.
Wunderbar.
Guten Tag.
Jetzt müssen wir
auf die nächste Ladung warten.
Welche Partei ist es?
Es ist die CVP.
Kostenbremse fürs Gesundheitswesen.
Der Wähleranteil der CVP hat sich
in den letzten 20 Jahren halbiert.
Helfen, diese Talfahrt zu bremsen -
das ist die grosse Aufgabe
von Gianna Luzio im kommenden Jahr.
FDP-Kampagnenleiter Matthias Leitner
plant schon seit Monaten
den Wahlkampf.
Er will die Parteimitglieder
von Tür zu Tür schicken.
Das ist neu für die Freisinnigen.
Heute Abend
findet die erste Schulung statt.
Ziel dieser Sitzung wäre,
schnell durch die ganze Schulung
durchzugehen,
abzumachen, wie wir was machen,
wer was sagt.
Damit wir
aufeinander abgestimmt sind.
Nicht aufs Geratewohl sollen die
FDPler durch die Quartiere ziehen,
sondern von einer App gesteuert.
Dorthin, wo am ehesten
neue Wähler zu holen sind.
Der datengestützte Wahlkampf
ist in der Schweiz angekommen.
Wir haben erkannt,
dass die Mobilisierung
eine unserer grossen Schwächen ist.
34 % der Bevölkerung
können sich vorstellen,
FDP zu wählen.
Wir schöpfen lediglich 16,4 % ab.
Wir müssen irgendwelche Wege gehen,
die neu sind,
die die Möglichkeiten
des digitalen Wahlkampfs,
des datenbasierten Wahlkampfs
nutzen können,
um unsere Wähler wirklich
an die Urne zu bringen.
* Beschwingte,
dumpfe Akkordeonklänge *
Wir müssen die SP überholen.
Wie viel es dann braucht,
weiss ich nicht.
Es wird sich zeigen.
Ich möchte mich nicht festlegen.
Ich hoffe, dass wir 2023
die ganze Kraft dieser Massnahme
auf den Boden bekommen.
Herzlich willkommen
auch von meiner Seite.
Ich bin stellvertretender
Generalsekretär
und verantwortlich für das Projekt
im Generalsekretariat.
Etwas verspätet kommt
Desiree Schreyer zu Schulung.
Sie wird eine der Ersten sein, die
App-gesteuert von Tür zu Tür geht.
Wie alle hier kandidiert sie
für den Zürcher Kantonsrat.
Danach will sie sich für
den Nationalrat aufstellen lassen.
Und jetzt ...
Bevor die FDP
ihre neue App national einsetzt,
sollen die Zürcher Kantonalpolitiker
sie testen -
vorerst noch als Rollenspiel.
Macht nicht auf.
Nein.
Guten Abend.
- Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Desiree Schreyer.
Ich bin für
die Kantonsratswahlen aufgestellt.
Worum geht es genau?
- Um die Wahlen.
Oh, sind bereits wieder Wahlen?
- Ja, genau.
Immer diese Wahlen. Interessiert
mich nicht so, die Politik.
Haben Sie sich schon entschieden?
Nein. Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich zur Wahl gehe.
Ich würde. Warum nicht?
Super. Vielen Dank. Schönen Abend.
- Ihnen auch. Auf Wiedersehen.
Ja.
Ich bin gespannt. Momentan habe ich
das Gefühl, dass es schwierig wird.
Aber wir werden sehen.
* "Tagesschau"-Signet *
In acht Monaten wählen
die Schweizerinnen und Schweizer
ein neues Parlament.
Die FDP möchte gerne die zweit-
stärkste Partei werden im Parlament.
Also die SP verdrängen. Im Moment
ist es ein Kopf-an-Kopf-Rennen.
Der grüne Steigflug hält an:
9,5 % würden derzeit Grün wählen.
Die SVP liegt immer noch deutlich
vorne mit 27 % Wähleranteil.
Aber sie verliert gemäss Umfrage
2,4 %.
Diana Gutjahr
hat etwas gegen Berufsparlamentarier.
Im familieneigenen Metallbaubetrieb
ist sie auf der Suche
nach einem Fotomotiv.
Hier will sie sich
als Frau der Wirtschaft zeigen.
Die SVP-Nationalrätin ist vor zwei
Jahren ins Parlament nachgerutscht.
Nun plant sie minutiös
die Verteidigung ihres Sitzes.
Wahlkampfleiter ist Roland Gutjahr,
Dianas Vater.
Mit der Aufhängung,
damit man sieht ...
Damit das Bild lebendig wirkt.
Das muss lebendig wirken.
Werber Stefan Ströbele
hilft dem Team Gutjahr
beim Ausfeilen
einer mehrstufigen Kampagne.
Du hast vorher gesagt, dass ihr eine
Vor- und eine Hauptkampagne macht.
Bei der Vorkampagne ist Diana
als Unternehmerin im Vordergrund.
Und zwar im gleichen Look und Feel
wie bei der Hauptkampagne.
Damit die Verbindung sofort da ist.
Die passen super zusammen.
Wir haben uns
noch einen Gag überlegt:
ein Türanhänger,
den wir machen könnten.
Die Leute mögen es immer,
wenn sie etwas mitnehmen können.
Oder etwas zum Anschauen usw.
Aber es sind Sekundenbruchteile, in
denen wir dich wieder rüberbringen.
Dann müssten wir schauen ...
Das würde wieder so aussehen, oder?
(Ströbele)
Ja, das ist alles in der Kampagne.
(Gutjahr) Ich würde das so machen:
direkt anhängen, mit Bostitch.
Das kannst du - zack, zack -
anhängen.
Du kannst es gut
in der Hand halten.
Beim anderen musst du
immer wieder aufmachen, reinwerfen.
Dann sind schon Sachen drin,
da kriegst du es kaum rein.
Eigentlich hängt das,
was wir jetzt tun,
sehr stark mit dem zusammen, was
man im Unternehmen auch tun muss.
Man muss ein Produkt anpreisen.
Wenn man ein gutes Produkt nicht
anpreist, bleibt man darauf sitzen.
Wenn du ein gutes Produkt hast,
musst du das dem Kunden auch zeigen.
Du musst rausgehen und es zeigen.
Dann hast du Erfolg.
Zu Hause sitzen mit einem
guten Produkt - da versauerst du.
Also doch ein Produkt?
- Ja.
Ich fühle mich gar nicht
als Produkt.
Ich würde mich wehren,
wenn es in diese Richtung ginge.
Aber wenn das, was man sieht oder
in der Diskussion gehört hat ...
Ich wehre mich, wenn es
für mich überhaupt nicht stimmt.
Denn ich bin eine Person.
Das sage ich immer wieder.
Schliesslich geht es
um meinen Kopf und meinen Namen.
Ich muss dahinterstehen können, kei-
ne dritte Person. Das ist wichtig.
(Alle) # Oh Thurgau, du Heimat,
# wie bist du so hold.
# La, la, la ...
# La, la, la, la, la, la, la.
* Juchzer *
Eine Kleinigkeit fehlt noch: die
Nominierung. Doch das ist Formsache.
So stehen wir alle gemeinsam für un-
sere Bürger und unsere Schweiz ein.
Denn wir kämpfen für ein freies,
eigenständiges Heimatland. Danke.
* Applaus *
Einstimmig zur Kandidatin gekürt.
Doch der SVP
steht ein schwieriges Jahr bevor.
Ich bin klar der Meinung,
dass überhaupt nichts sicher ist.
Am 20. Oktober ist sicher,
wer gewählt ist.
Vorher ist überhaupt nichts sicher.
* Beschwingte Akkordeonklänge *
Florence Brenzikofer hat sich
den richtigen Wohnort ausgesucht.
Von über 2'000 Schweizer Gemeinden
hat Oltingen vor vier Jahren
am zweitgrünsten gewählt.
Jetzt will die grüne Brenzikofer den
Sprung in den Nationalrat schaffen.
Brenzikofer arbeitet Teilzeit
als Sekundarlehrerin in Liestal.
Bonjour Callem.
Bonjour Alusha.
Bonjour Tiago.
Nous allons faire un voyage
dans differentes villes.
Die Demonstrationen der Klimajugend
haben in der Schweiz
gerade erst begonnen.
Man kann vorerst nur ahnen,
wie sehr die Klimadebatte den
Schweizer Wahlkampf dominieren wird.
Sollte ein Schüler
in der Schule politisiert werden?
Nicht im Sinne, dass ich ihnen meine
persönliche Meinung verklickere.
Das mache ich nicht. Aber ich finde,
Schule darf politisch sein.
Der Staatskundeunterricht
dürfte schon viel früher drankommen.
Einige Sekundarschüler interes-
sieren sich für politische Themen.
Das zeigen auch die Klimademos,
wo bereits sehr junge Schüler/-innen
auf die Strasse gehen.
Florence Brenzikofer erwartet
Parteikolleginnen und -kollegen
zu Besuch.
Sie führt im Moment
gleich zwei Wahlkämpfe.
Denn vor den eidgenössischen
stehen dieses Jahr in Baselland
auch noch kantonale Wahlen an.
Ich dachte,
wir beginnen mit Kartenschreiben.
Ihr seht einen ganzen Stapel Karten.
Dann ist die Frage,
was wir schreiben wollen.
"Danke, dass Sie Liste 7 wählen."
Ich würde
keinen zu langen Text schreiben.
Ich fände es schön,
wenn alle von Hand unterschreiben.
"Liste 7, eine gute Wahl."
* Lachen *
Übrigens: Am Samstag
ist die SVP im Dorf unterwegs.
Das habe ich heute
in der Zeitung gelesen.
Genau ...
Was machen sie?
- Es gibt Gulasch.
Ich gehe sie besuchen.
Es ist eine reine Männerliste.
Das können wir
ein bisschen aufmischen.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Das ist unsere erste Schreibaktion.
Das haben wir bisher nicht gemacht.
Es geht darum,
Personen anzuschreiben,
die aus dem weiteren Umfeld stammen,
also nicht unbedingt Sympathisanten
und Mitglieder
der Grünen Gelterkinden sind,
sondern Personen, von denen wir den-
ken, die könnten uns Stimmen geben.
Die Teller
könnt ihr auch schon bringen.
Die Grünen starten mit besten
Voraussetzungen ins Wahljahr.
Doch die Chance,
dass Florence Brenzikofer
im Oktober Nationalrätin wird,
scheint im Moment noch klein.
(Schreyer) Das ist diese Strasse.
Die FDP-App führt Desiree Schreyer an
die Rainstrasse im Zürcher Kreis 2.
Als Gast ist Parteipräsidentin
Petra Gössi dabei.
Frau Gössi, bei Minustemperaturen
im Dunkeln Türen abzuklopfen,
macht das das Parteivolk gerne?
Das gehört dazu.
Früher ging man v.a. in Restaurants,
an den Stammtisch,
konnte dort politisieren.
Wenn man zu den Leuten will,
muss man das in seiner Freizeit tun.
Wir sind alle Milizpolitiker.
Das gehört dazu.
Gerade in solchen Momenten
ergeben sich interessante Gespräche.
Desiree Schreyer hat kaum Chancen
auf die Wahl ins Kantonsparlament,
trotzdem setzt sie viel Zeit ein
für ihre Partei.
Guten Abend.
Hier sind Schreyer und Rueff.
Sind Sie Herr Kriess?
Ja.
Guten Abend. Wir sind von der FDP.
Dürfen wir Ihnen
zwei Fragen stellen? Max. drei.
Ich komme schnell runter.
Guten Abend.
- Sie sind spät unterwegs.
Kriess ist mein Name.
- Rueff.
Desiree Schreyer.
- Frau Schreyer.
Wir würden gerne zwei, drei Fragen
zur Politik stellen,
dazu, was Sie beschäftigt.
Wir würden Notizen machen.
Wenn das für Sie in Ordnung ist.
- Schiessen Sie los.
Sonst frieren Sie noch mehr.
- Nein, sonst wird Ihnen kalt.
Was ist das dringendste Problem?
Altersvorsorge.
- Altersvorsorge.
Dann auch,
dass die Leute immer älter werden.
Zu wenig Pflegepersonal.
Danke.
- Also, ungefähr.
Vielen Dank. Wen werden Sie
bei den nächsten Wahlen wählen?
Wen? Sie.
- Super.
Und Sie auch.
Toi, toi, toi.
- Vielen Dank.
Tschüss.
- Auf Wiedersehen. Schönen Abend.
* Türsummer *
Wieso habe ich hier nur die Fünf?
Guten Abend.
* Türsummer *
Sie machen zumindest alle auf.
Was ist das dringendste Problem,
das man in der Schweiz lösen sollte?
Wir sind von der FDP.
Desiree Schreyer und Sonja Rueff.
Wen Sie wählen,
wissen Sie noch nicht?
Danke schön, schönen Abend.
Aus Worten
sollen schliesslich Daten werden.
(Rueff) Du kannst
nur etwas antippen.
Es war alles eingetippt,
dann ist das App abgestürzt.
Ich hätte nur noch ...
- Abgestürzt?
Deshalb musste ich es
nochmals eingeben. Aber wir ...
Es sind ja nicht viele Fragen.
Theoretisch ist der Check gemacht.
Man muss ja
auch nicht alles eingeben.
"Was denken Sie, was hatte
die Person für ein Geschlecht?"
Das muss man ja nicht eingeben.
Hallo.
- Wie lief es bei euch?
(Gössi) Wie war's?
- War super.
Bei uns auch.
Es war so gut. Wirklich.
Sie haben es richtig genossen,
dass man ihnen zuhört.
"Einwanderung ist ein Problem." Sie
wollten über Flüchtlinge sprechen.
Diese Flüchtlinge,
jene Flüchtlinge.
(Gössi) Was waren die Hauptprobleme?
Migration und Altersvorsorge.
- AHV.
Was?
- Altersvorsorge.
Bei euch?
- (Beide) Umwelt.
Umwelt?
- Praktisch überall.
Beim Tür-zu-Tür-Wahlkampf
im Zürcher Kreis 2
erscheint die Umwelt
auf dem Radar der FDP -
und wird bis zu den Wahlen
nicht verschwinden.
* "Tagesschau"-Signet *
Im Bereich Umwelt und Klima
brauche es
konkrete praxistaugliche und
griffige Massnahmen für unser Land.
In den letzten Monaten wurde ich
überall, wo ich unterwegs war,
immer wieder
auf die Umweltpolitik angesprochen.
Die Begrünung
des parteipolitischen FDP-Terrains
löst parteiintern
nicht nur Applaus aus.
Petra Gössi macht ernst:
Ihre umweltpolitische Kehrtwende
soll -
anders als in früheren Jahren ...
Es ist der 1. Mai, Tag der Arbeit.
Anna Gallati
bereitet das Herzstück
des sozialdemokratischen Wahlkampfs
vor: die Basiskampagne.
Das ist gut, das ist super.
Sie ist eine sog. Campaignerin.
Ich rufe mal Franco an.
Wir haben mega Glück: Er antwortet.
Wir sind ja per du mit ihnen.
- Ja.
Genau. Mit den Genossen.
Wenn ihr sie kennt, könnt ihr
ganz leger mit ihnen sprechen.
Am Anfang
ist das für viele schwierig.
Du bist im Berufskontext,
aber es ist ein Freund.
Aber ihr könnt das
mega freundschaftlich machen.
Dann rufst du ihn an und sagst:
"Hoi Franco, geht's gut?"
Blablabla.
"Ich habe gesehen,
du kommst telefonieren. Mega geil."
"Wir brauchen jeden, der kommt.
Auch dich."
"Du bist eh gut" - wenn du
ihn kennst, sonst lässt du das weg.
"Du hast dich angemeldet
für den 2.5."
"Dienstag. In Weinfelden."
Stimmen ist ein Teil. Das andere
ist der Job, den ich mache.
Ich finde, dass Mitbestimmung
mega, mega wichtig ist
und im Alltag vieler Menschen
nicht präsent ist.
Ich glaube, wir können
einen Teil dazu beitragen,
dass es vielleicht präsenter wird
und sie ihr Stimmrecht wahrnehmen.
Im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen hier
hat Anna Gallati
schon Erfahrung mit Kampagnenjobs.
38 Frauen und Männer
werden von der Parteileitung für
ihre Arbeit in den Kantonen geschult.
Vier Tage büffeln
im Ausbildungscamp.
Jetzt haben sicher alle Hunger.
Deshalb das Wort an Marco, den Koch.
Heute gibt es einen
Randen-Apfel-Hirseburger.
Und einen Sellerie-Karottensalat.
Plus eine Joghurtsauce
und ein selbstgemachtes Ketchup.
Parteipräsident Christian Levrat
kommt persönlich,
um die Campaigner auf
das gemeinsame Ziel einzuschwören.
Salut.
- Hallo, salut.
Was ich euch sagen wollte, ist,
dass ihr zentraler Teil
unseres Wahlkampfs seid.
Da ist etwas, das mich
seit zehn Jahren begleitet:
diese Überzeugung, dass wir
näher zu den Leuten kommen müssen.
Die Zeiten, in denen man
einen Stand aufstellte und wartete,
bis die Leute auf einen zukamen,
sind langsam vorbei.
Wenn Sie wirklich Leute erreichen
wollen, müssen Sie zu ihnen.
Entweder direkt oder per Telefon.
Das ermöglicht es, eine viel
grössere Anzahl Personen zu treffen.
Es ist dringend notwendig,
dass wir einen aktiven und erfolg-
reichen Wahlkampf machen können.
Die SP hat als erste Schweizer Partei
auf diese amerikanische
Wahlkampfmethode gesetzt.
Das brachte ihr vor vier Jahren
ein Extraprozent Wähleranteil.
Diesen Erfolg
will die nun SP übertreffen.
Anna Gallati und ihre
Campaignerkolleginnen und -kollegen
haben fünf Monate Zeit,
um das gesteckte Ziel zu erreichen.
* Animierte Klänge *
Heute will Gianna Luzio
die Nationalratskandidatinnen
und -kandidaten ihrer Partei
fit für den Wahlkampf machen.
Ja, weisst du, wo die Drei ist?
Die Drei ist bei mir hinten.
Wer kennt den Leitsatz der CVP
für das Wahljahr 2019?
Wie heisst er?
- "Wir halten die Schweiz zusammen."
Super. Wunderbar.
"Wir halten die Schweiz zusammen."
Wir wollen jetzt zusammen versuchen,
diesen Satz mit Inhalt zu füllen.
Mit politischen Inhalten.
Und zwar so, dass es tauglich ist
für das Gespräch auf der Strasse.
Du musst mir helfen
mit deinem Namen.
Karin.
- Hallo, Karin.
Luzio spielt die kritische Frau
auf dem Marktplatz.
Wir haben
das beste Gesundheitswesen der Welt.
Wie möchten Sie denn sparen?
Die CVP
ist doch eine verstaubte Partei.
Was hat die denn
mit Digitalisierung am Hut?
Ich bin seit fünf Jahren
pensioniert, ich finde das super.
Und ich will nicht,
dass meine Rente gekürzt wird.
Wenn ich etwas
fürs Klima machen will, Josef,
wähle ich doch die Grünen.
- Nein.
Es geht in Bern oben
einfach wieder mal nicht vorwärts.
Absolut.
Deshalb arbeiten wir daran.
Das ist genau die Politik,
die wir möchten:
eine fortschrittliche,
die die Schweiz weiterbringt.
Ich würde sagen, dafür gibt es
einen grossen Applaus. Vielen Dank.
"Wir wollen eine Schweiz, in der
Gesundheit für alle zugänglich
und bezahlbar ist."
Da ist wieder dieses berühmte "und".
Wir versuchen, die Komplexität der
CVP-Politik einfach darzustellen.
Denn es ist so, wenn man
die Schweiz zusammenhalten will,
hat man keine einfachen Antworten
und Lösungen parat.
Das ist logisch und auch richtig so.
Deshalb ist dieses "und" so wichtig.
Jetzt sage ich noch vielen Dank und
wünsche euch eine gute Heimreise.
Nachher sehen wir uns sicher
noch beim Apero. Vielen Dank.
Diana Gutjahr
hat schon ein VIP-Frühstück
und einen halben Arbeitstag
hinter sich.
Jetzt fährt sie zu ihrer
Wahlkampferöffnung nach Amriswil.
Kannst du
auf die andere Seite fahren?
Nachher?
- Kannst jetzt schon rüber.
Soll ich wenden oder wie?
Also neben die ...
Dort hinten kommen Tische hin.
Damit die Leute an der Wärme sind.
Dann kommt der Rauch
nach hinten von dir.
Dann bekommen die Leute Hunger.
Oben der Reissverschluss.
Das freut mich aber. Das freut mich
aber, dass du hier bist.
Ei, ei, ei!
- Möchtest du eine Wurst?
Das Wetter ist nicht so gut,
aber die Leute
lassen sich davon nicht beirren.
Es geht um den persönlichen Kontakt.
Dass man die Leute persönlich abholt
und sie informiert,
dass wieder Wahlen sind.
Es freut mich, dass trotz Regen
so viele Leute gekommen sind
und mit mir den Wahlauftakt feiern.
Hoi.
- Hoi, komm rein.
Schön.
Sehr geehrte Frau Nationalrätin
Diana Gutjahr.
Wir finden es super, liebe Diana,
dass du wieder in den Wahlkampf
steigst, das auf dich nimmst.
Wir wissen,
was das alles heisst für dich,
wie viel Kraft das braucht.
Das finden wir sensationell.
Für mich ist ein Traum, dass
irgendwann ein Glöcklein bimmelt
und es dann heisst:
"Gewählt ist mit 128 Stimmen
Frau Nationalrätin Diana Gutjahr."
* Lachen *
Liebe Diana, viel Kraft!
Einen grossen Applaus von allen
Anwesenden und von deinem Team.
Vielen Dank.
* Jazzige Alphornklänge *
* "Schweiz aktuell"-Signet *
Die FDP
verliert einen ihrer zwei Sitze.
Heute Morgen
hätten nur wenige darauf gewettet,
dass die FDP tatsächlich
einen Sitz verliert.
Die Klimademonstrationen
von Tausenden von Jugendlichen
in Zürich und in anderen Städten ...
Für die Zürcher Bürgerlichen hin-
gegen wird der Wahltag zum Debakel.
Eine Woche nach der FDP-Niederlage
bei den Zürcher Wahlen.
Heute hätte der Tag sein sollen,
an dem Desiree Schreyer zur
Nationalratskandidatin gekürt wird.
Doch sie steht nicht auf der Liste.
Ich war enttäuscht.
Man muss es einfach nehmen,
wie es ist.
Was genau dazu geführt hat ...
Ja, ich hoffe,
dass ich das noch erfahren werde.
Die Findungskommission
wird weder den Kandidierenden
noch der Delegiertenversammlung
irgendwelche Begründungen abliefern,
weshalb eine bestimmte Person
auf der Liste ist oder nicht
oder weshalb
auf einem bestimmten Listenplatz.
Vielen Dank.
Ich mache keinen Hehl daraus, ich
wäre gerne auf der Liste gewesen.
Ich bin nicht drauf.
Ich war auch nicht
in der Findungskommission.
Das ist eine
wahnsinnig schwierige Aufgabe.
Ich möchte der Findungskommission
für ihre Arbeit danken.
Aber ich weiss nicht,
wie man bei dieser Liste
die Strategie vergessen konnte.
Wir hatten mal
ein Strategiepapier veröffentlicht,
wonach uns in Zukunft
die Frauen fehlen.
Dass wir langfristig gesehen
weniger Frauen haben,
weil wir weniger im Gemeinderat
usw. ... Dass man aufstocken muss.
Dann sollte man doch mindestens
dort, wo es um Listenfüller geht,
wo einfach
diese Linie zuunterst ist,
wenigstens dort
jungen Frauen die Chance geben,
sich bekannt zu machen.
Ich kann dem nicht zustimmen.
(Thomas Vogel) Danke, Desiree.
Ich habe vielleicht
andere persönliche Präferenzen,
aber egal,
was heute Abend herauskommt:
Wenn wir die Liste ablehnen,
ändert sich nicht viel.
Wir arbeiten mit den Leuten,
die wir haben.
Wir Freisinnigen sind
die Speerspitze der Bürgerlichen
im Kanton Zürich - dieses Signal
müssen wir heute aussenden.
Wir möchten
keine internen Kämpfe ausfechten
und damit
unseren politischen Gegnern helfen.
Besten Dank.
(Thomas Vogel)
Wer dieser Liste zustimmen möchte,
soll das bitte
mit dem Wahlzettel bekunden.
Wer diese Liste ablehnt,
soll es ebenfalls
mit dem Wahlzettel bezeugen.
Sie haben
der Nationalratswahlliste zugestimmt
mit 100 Ja gegen 58 Nein
und zwölf Enthaltungen.
Die Zürcher FDP-Liste
bleibt unverändert.
Für Desiree Schreyer
ist der Wahlkampf beendet,
noch bevor er richtig begonnen hat.
* "Schweiz aktuell"-Signet *
In Luzern und im Baselbiet
ist Wahlsonntag.
Guten Nachmittag.
Das ist "Schweiz aktuell extra".
Die Grünen
sind auch für Bürgerliche wählbar.
Die Sitzgewinne der Grünen
gingen auf Kosten der SVP.
Die Grünen können
am meisten Zugewinne verzeichnen.
Die Kantonsparlamente
werden generell deutlich grüner
und deutlich linker.
Der Mann für die Regieanweisung.
Fraktionsausflug der Grünen
in beide Basel.
Gastgeberin Florence Brenzikofer
ist frisch wiedergewählte Landrätin -
mit einem Glanzresultat.
Jetzt geht's um den Nationalrat.
Die bisherige grüne Nationalrätin
Maya Graf will Ständerätin werden.
Schafft sie das, würde Brenzikofer
in den Nationalrat nachrutschen.
Es war cool. Ein Kontrastprogramm.
Zuerst waren wir im Grünen,
und jetzt hier.
Es ist
überhaupt noch nichts gewonnen.
Ich zähle auf euch.
Ich kann es so sagen:
Es ist meiner Meinung nach
schwieriger,
wenn man Rückenwind hat,
als wenn man
gegen den Wind ankämpft.
Denn dann besteht die Gefahr,
nachlässig zu werden.
Ich danke euch für euren Einsatz.
Ich zähle auf euch.
Ich sehe uns auch
als Bewegungspartei.
Immer noch.
Wir gehen auf die Strasse.
Und das müssen wir bis zum Schluss.
Wir müssen präsent sein.
Das haben wir
aus den letzten Wahlkämpfen gelernt.
Und wir haben diesen langen Atem
bis zum 20. Oktober
oder bis Ende November.
Bei den letzten Wahlen sind Flo und
ich am Ende nur noch Bahn gefahren.
Wir zogen
mit unseren ganzen Kampagnensachen
von Dorf zu Dorf.
Wir haben uns schon überlegt,
in der S3 zu übernachten.
Mit den Wahlplakaten war das gut.
Die Leute wussten, was wir wollten.
Bravo!
Setzen wir uns dort auf die Treppe?
Es ist Frühsommer.
Campaignerin Anna Gallati
steckt mitten in der ersten Phase
des SP-Basiswahlkampfs.
Der Grund, wieso wir das tun ...
Nur ein kurzer Abriss.
Wir wollen mit den Leuten
in den Dialog kommen.
Wir wollen keine Einwegkommunikation
im Sinne von:
Die Politik sagt,
die Leute hören zu.
Es geht nicht darum,
Leute von uns zu überzeugen.
Ihr müsst nicht die Haltung haben:
"Wählt SP! Wählt SP! Wählt SP!"
Wir wollen wissen,
was die Leute interessiert.
Deshalb sprechen wir auch mit allen.
Es gibt keine Listen
von Gesprächspartnern.
Wir gehen in ein Haus
und schauen, wer dort ist.
Ihr seid nicht alleine
unterwegs im Kanton.
Das Team Emmen ist soeben gestartet
und hat ein Foto geschickt.
Ich zeige es euch.
Auch in Kriens sind sie unterwegs.
Wir sind ein grosses Team.
Das ist das Team Emmen,
das euch grüsst.
Cool. Toi, toi, toi.
Viel Spass und gute Gespräche.
Aufeinander abgestimmt und
mit Gesprächsleitfaden ausgerüstet
klopfen SP-Mitglieder
die Luzerner Innenstadt ab.
(Frau durch Gegensprechanlage)
Hallo.
Hier ist Dorothee Kipfer
von der SP Stadt Luzern.
Dürfen wir ein paar Fragen stellen?
Dürfen wir reinkommen?
* Unverständliche Antwort *
Pardon.
Von der SP Stadt Luzern.
Wir haben ein paar Fragen.
Wir befragen die Leute im Quartier.
* Unverständliche Antwort *
Was hat sie gesagt?
Haben Sie "Nein, danke" gesagt?
* Unverständliche Antwort *
Schon okay. Macht nichts.
Ja, ich komme mir etwas lästig vor.
Aber es muss sein.
Wie die Zeugen Jehovas,
die aufdringlich überall klingeln.
Und wehe, wenn man drückt
und nicht fragt, wer draussen ist.
Dann hat man sie am Hals.
Aber ich möchte
nicht so aufdringlich sein.
Ich möchte ihnen klarmachen,
dass es nicht wehtut.
Haben wir hier schon geklingelt?
- Ja.
"Wir haben Sie leider verpasst."
Das ganze Haus? Hängen wir das hin?
Ja, hierhin.
Wir gehen trotzdem zur Nummer 15.
- Wir gehen zur 15.
Anna Gallati trägt die Verantwortung
für die Tür-zu-Tür-Aktion in Luzern.
Campaigner sind die einzig Bezahlten
im SP-Basiswahlkampf.
Es sind alle freiwillig hier.
Es ist ihre Freizeit.
Wenn die Sachen dann nicht da sind,
ist es mühsam. Das darf nicht sein.
Darum braucht es
diese Koordination im Hintergrund.
Insgesamt 30 Freiwillige sind an
diesem Samstag in Luzern unterwegs.
Hallo.
* Sie lacht. *
Habe ich bei Ihnen geklingelt?
SP Stadt Luzern.
Sie kommt im Nachthemd.
Im Herbst sind Wahlen,
aber wir beginnen früh,
Kontakt zu den Leuten in der Stadt
zu knüpfen.
Wir könnten zwei, drei Fragen
über die Gesundheit stellen.
Oder über das Klima.
Oder die Arbeitswelt.
Oder die Gleichstellung.
- Das hätte ich gewählt.
Gleichstellung
ist für Sie ein Thema? - Ja.
Geht es Ihnen hauptsächlich
um Lohngleichheit?
Oder um Sexismusbekämpfung,
weil die Frau in vielen Situationen
immer noch übergangen wird?
Was ist Ihnen wichtig?
Es geht mir eher
um die Sexismusdebatte.
Beim Lohn bin ich persönlich nicht
betroffen von Lohnungleichheit.
Aber man spürt
andere Sachen im Alltag.
Das ist immer wieder ein Thema.
Es wäre mir wichtig, dass man
die Aufmerksamkeit darauf lenkt.
Richtig viel los war heute
auf Schweizer Strassen und Plätzen
an diesem 14. Juni.
Allein 4'000 bis 5'000 Frauen
versammelten sich am Vormittag
vor dem Bundeshaus.
Sie demonstrieren heute für die
Vereinbarkeit von Beruf und Familie,
für Lohngleichheit
und sehr vieles mehr.
In der Schweiz beteiligten sich
Hunderttausende Frauen
am nationalen Streiktag.
Diana Gutjahr geht nicht an
den Frauenstreik, sie geht wandern.
Das "St. Galler Tagblatt"
hat drei Ostschweizer Prominente
zur Bergtour eingeladen.
Für die Website der Zeitung
wird der ganze Tag live getickert -
für Gutjahr
eine willkommene Plattform.
Ich bin ein Mensch,
der auch gerne das Private zeigt.
Darum bin ich gespannt,
was mich diese zwei Tage,
hoffentlich sind es zwei Tage,
erwartet.
Moderator Marco Fritsche
und Hackbrettspieler Nicolas Senn
sind Gutjahrs Weggefährten.
Auf dem Programm
steht die Königstour:
ein 80 km langer Zweitäger
im Alpstein.
Diana, wie läuft's?
- Relativ gut.
Das Herz pumpt. Zum Glück
ist es nicht so warm. Alles gut.
Und dann kommen solche Absätze.
Ich habe zu kurze Beine.
* Schweres Atmen *
Ich habe mich schon lange nicht mehr
so gefreut, irgendwo anzukommen.
Völlig sauer?
- Oh Gott.
84 km über 5'000 Höhenmeter -
war das eine gute Idee?
Momentan
habe ich einfach nur Hunger.
Und ich habe kalt.
Es ist nass. Es hat geregnet.
Die letzten Meter hat man mir
noch mit dem Rucksack geholfen.
Hast du das gepostet?
Bitte zurückschauen!
Ja, sehr gut.
Eins, zwei, drei ... und los!
Alles Gute.
Nach 30 km Auf und Ab
in den Appenzeller Bergen
kommen bei Diana Gutjahr zur
Müdigkeit noch Knieschmerzen dazu.
Gutjahr muss die Wanderung
nach einem Tag abbrechen.
Die Wählergunst
will hart erkämpft sein.
Wenn man es so sehen will, ja.
Die 30 km
waren auch für mich sehr hart.
Aber es war spannend, diese Tour
mit dieser Gruppe zu machen.
Es gab einen Liveticker
im "Tagblatt".
Wir haben jeweils gesehen,
wie viele Leute zugeschaltet waren.
Viele haben sich dafür interessiert.
Es waren über den Tag verteilt
doch einige Leser.
Es war sicher eine gute Möglichkeit,
sich zu platzieren
und sich für einmal nicht politisch,
sondern privat zu zeigen.
30'000 Besucher
hat der Liveticker am ersten Tag.
Ein Ausflug, der sich für Diana
Gutjahr trotz Schmerzen gelohnt hat.
* "Tagesschau"-Signet *
Die Schweiz vor dem Wahlherbst.
Im Oktober
wird das Parlament neu gewählt.
Es deutet alles
auf einen Linksrutsch hin.
Für die FDP zeigt das Wahlbarometer
einen Abwärtstrend.
Der FDP schadet offenbar
ihre Klimadebatte.
Ob sich eine allfällige
Neupositionierung der FDP
punkto Klimapolitik positiv auf die
Wahlen im Herbst auswirken würde,
ist fraglich.
Matthias Leitner steht mit der FDP
nicht dort, wo er gerne möchte.
Knapp drei Monate vor den Wahlen
treibt das Thema Klima
die Freisinnigen mehr um,
als ihnen lieb ist.
Ich glaube,
das Aufkommen der Klimafrage ...
Wir konnten dort keine konsistente,
liberale Lösung bieten.
Das hat dazu geführt,
dass sich einige sagten:
"Wenn ihr auf eine so wichtige Frage
keine konsistente Antwort bietet,
suchen wir uns eine Alternative."
Treffen
in einer Zürcher Werbeagentur.
Hier bespricht das FDP-Wahlkampfteam
die nächsten Schritte der Kampagne
und analysiert die Lage im Detail.
Ich gehe schnell die Liste durch.
Gesundheit.
Ich gehe im Moment gemäss
gut informierten Kreisen davon aus,
dass die Prämien
nicht so stark steigen werden.
Mit "nicht so stark"
meine ich etwas um 2 % herum.
Vielleicht sogar tiefer.
Migration.
Wenn die Zahlen so bleiben und die
Diskussion weiter auf dem Feld ist,
ob man sogar
ein Asylzentrum schliessen muss,
hat die SVP in diesem Wahlkampf
langsam ein massives Problem.
Für uns sind das gute Neuigkeiten.
Mit der SP müssen wir
über Altersvorsorge, Wirtschaft
und Bilaterale diskutieren.
Ich glaube, dort würden sie sich
gerne mit uns streiten.
Dann würden sie stattfinden.
Das Problem ist: Sie finden auf
diesem Thema einfach nicht statt.
Wir möchten nicht länger auf
diesem Thema aktiv sein. - Genau.
Glaubwürdigkeit haben wir
bei den Themen Altersvorsorge
und Wirtschaft.
Dort haben wir auch
keinen internen Graben.
Wenn wir uns aber zu stark
auf die Umweltpolitik konzentrieren,
werden wir immer auch
die beiden Seiten innerhalb
der Partei aufeinander loshetzen.
Ich fände es viel wichtiger,
ein neues Thema zu bespielen.
In diesem Bereich ...
Ich finde es immer noch wichtig.
Die Generationenfrage
müssen wir aufnehmen.
Da müssen wir Antworten liefern.
Das ist dann auch
das Dach für die Altersvorsorge.
Damit bespielen wir aber
andere Themen.
Wir können nicht nur
auf einem Thema ...
Das haben wir jetzt
vier Monate lang besetzt.
Es haben praktisch nur wir
darauf stattgefunden.
Jetzt müssen wir weitergehen.
Wir haben jetzt unsere Antworten.
4 1/2 Std. dauert es,
bis alle Themen besprochen sind.
Ich bin froh,
konnten wir alles diskutieren.
Zuerst muss sich alles etwas setzen.
Morgen schaue ich es mir an
und lese das Protokoll.
Dann werde ich einige Dinge
zu Ende denken können.
Aber heute bin ich einfach fertig.
Auch wenn die FDP das Thema Klima
nun gerne abhaken möchte -
es bleibt Wahlkampfthema Nummer 1.
* "Tagesschau"-Signet *
Der Wahlkampf
für die Wahlen im Herbst läuft an -
u.a. auch mit Plakatsujets.
Äpfel mit Würmern -
wir sprechen von diesem SVP-Plakat.
Ein Wurm macht den Apfel kaputt.
So, wie die anderen Parteien
die Schweiz zerstören.
Jede Partei macht es so,
wie sie kann.
Die SVP kann es halt so.
Mitten im Wirbel um das Apfelplakat
besucht Diana Gutjahr
die Delegiertenversammlung der SVP.
Das Plakat hat die Thurgauerin
in die Bredouille gebracht.
Äpfel haben eine grosse Bedeutung
für den Kanton Thurgau.
Ich kann nachvollziehen,
dass man nicht dahintersteht
und es nicht so toll findet.
Der Apfel
wird mit einem Kanton verbunden
und hat positive Eigenschaften.
Jetzt ist der Apfel da.
Wir machen das Beste daraus.
Wie stehen Sie persönlich dazu?
Ich fand das mit dem Apfel
nicht so appetitlich.
Die Parteileitung
hat aber eine strategische Funktion.
Ich habe eine operative Funktion
als Nationalrätin.
Ich möchte mich
mit Sachthemen auseinandersetzen
und nicht mit irgendwelchen Bildern.
Viel Symbolik gibt's am Parteifest
und harte Worte.
Die SVP will ihre Basis sieben Wochen
vor den Wahlen wachrütteln.
Wie wollen Sie, und jetzt bin ich
bei diesem Apfelplakat ...
Wie wollen Sie eine solche Sauerei,
die die anderen Parteien machen -
angefangen mit Verfassungsbruch
bei der Massenzuwanderung,
Nichtumsetzung
krimineller Ausländer,
Verschieben von allen relevanten
Geschäften auf nach den Wahlen,
um vorher so zu tun, als ob ...
Wie wollen Sie eine solche Sauerei
besser darstellen
als mit dem Apfel,
der von Maden angefressen wurde?
Wie?
Es braucht uns in diesem Wahlkampf,
weil die vereinigten Linken
und Netten uns zerstören wollen -
unter gütiger Mithilfe
der vierten Macht im Staat.
Und da müssen wir Gegensteuer geben.
Ich danke Ihnen.
* Applaus *
Diana Gutjahr versucht,
sich aus der Apfelplakat-Diskussion
möglichst rauszuhalten.
Die Gespräche bleiben unverfänglich.
Wenn der "Blick" es aufgreift,
ist gut. - Ja, das ist gut.
Tschau. Diese Bluse habe ich auch.
Sie ist in der "Schweizer
Illustrierten" abgebildet.
Wir sind quasi Zwillinge.
Tschau, Magdalena. Lars.
- Sali.
Die schlechten Umfragewerte der SVP -
an diesem Samstag in Sattel
kein Thema.
Hier herrscht Optimismus,
zwangsläufig.
Denn anders lässt sich
ein Wahlkampf nicht bestreiten.
Anna Gallati ist kein Morgenmensch.
Doch der Kampagnenjob
frisst viel Zeit.
Sich abzugrenzen von der Arbeit
fällt schwer.
Die Zeiten der Freizeit
verändern sich massiv.
Gestern Abend bis 21 Uhr.
Heute sind es nur
der Morgen und der Nachmittag.
Das verändert sich sehr.
Ich habe eine E-Mail von einer
Freundin gekriegt, die schrieb:
"Wann sieht man dich wieder?"
Es verändert sich.
Hast du das gewusst? - Ja.
Ich habe mich darauf eingelassen.
Ich wusste aber nicht,
dass es so heftig ist
und es etwas mit mir macht.
Das habe ich anders eingeschätzt.
Was macht es mit dir?
Ich lerne, durchzubeissen und die
Motivation zu behalten in Momenten,
in denen ich müde bin und eigentlich
keine Leute um mich herum möchte.
Mit 150'000 Menschen
will die SP im Vorfeld der Wahlen
das Gespräch führen.
Campaignerin Anna Gallatis
Hauptjob ist,
für diese Freiwilligenarbeit
Parteimitglieder zu begeistern.
Wir wollen, dass möglichst
viele Leute an die Urne gehen.
Wir rufen sie im Vorfeld an.
Ich wollte dich fragen,
ob du dir vorstellen könntest ...
Ja. Ja.
Cool.
Hey, Kilian, wo ist ...
Mit Kilian Koch leitet Gallati
den Basiswahlkampf in Luzern.
Du bekommst noch eine E-Mail, wenn
ich für dich eine Anmeldung erfasse.
Und wir rufen nochmals an,
damit du weisst ... Super.
Zweimal im Monat treffen sie sich
mit Campaignern anderer Kantone
zum Austausch.
Anna und ihre Kollegen müssen
der nationalen und regionalen Leitung
Rechenschaft darüber abgelegen,
ob sie auf Kurs sind.
Machen wir die Runde!
Wie ging es letzte Woche?
Was lief gut? Was ärgerte euch?
Wir begannen am Montag
mit dem Mitgliedertelefon.
Das war super.
Bis am Mittwoch, als ich merkte,
dass mir Leute absagten,
von denen ich es schade finde,
dass sie nicht mitmachen.
Und andere
kämpfen sich durch diese Anlässe,
obwohl sie es ungern machen
und viel Überwindung brauchen.
Da musste ich Barbara anrufen
und etwas Frust ablassen. - Gut.
Wie steht es mit dem
Motivationslevel von 1 bis 10?
12 natürlich.
- Ah, okay.
To-Dos der letzten Woche:
das mit den zugesagten Aktivitäten.
Leute, die Flyer verteilen.
Wer hat das noch nicht angeschaut
und weitergeleitet?
Du hast es ...
Ich habe es noch nicht gemacht.
Hast du es
bis Ende nächste Woche erledigt?
Mit kleinen Abstrichen
sind hier alle im Zeitplan.
Florence Brenzikofer
und Tochter Nuria
sind unterwegs an die
Steinstoss-Schweizermeisterschaften
in ihrem Nachbardorf.
Ein guter Monat vor den Wahlen
ist jeder Tag ein Wahlkampftag.
Auch Ständeratskandidatin Maya Graf
ist hier.
Sie ist nervös,
denn im Vergleich zur Konkurrenz
haben die Grünen
viel weniger Wahlplakate aufgehängt.
Ich habe mich nirgends gesehen.
- Doch. Dort oben.
Aber in Gelterkinden
ist kein einiges Plakat von mir.
Wir haben
dieses Kontingent an Plakaten.
Sie können nichts dafür. Sie
haben keine Maya-Plakate bestellt.
Weisst du, wie viele?
- Nein. - Ah, ist ja egal.
Es kommen noch mehr.
Aber ich musste es selbst bezahlen.
- Ja.
Egal. Lassen wir das.
Wir haben nicht so viele Plakate.
Die Leute sagen:
"Ihr hängt nirgends."
Gewisse im Kanton
hängen bis zu 400-fach.
Ich habe 30 und 30.
Also 60 im ganzen Kanton.
Das ist nicht so viel.
Nein.
Caroline Mall hat ungefähr 300.
Echt?
- Ja.
Maya Graf hat heute noch ganz andere
Herausforderungen zu bewältigen.
Auch sie muss steinstossen -
für einen Newsbeitrag
zum Ständeratswahlkampf.
Gehört es zum Wahlkampf,
dass man solche Sachen macht?
Bei den Ständeratskandidaten
offenbar schon, ja.
Das Steinstoss-Experiment
dauert länger als geplant.
Brenzikofer und Graf müssten jetzt
zusammen weiter zum nächsten Termin.
ÖKO-JOB.
Wo ist das?
- Am Bahnhof.
Beim Bahnhof. - Sonst rufst du an.
Wir müssen jetzt los.
SRF 4 News, "Die Freitagsrunde".
Wir sprechen
über die Wahlkampagne der CVP,
die diese Woche
zu reden gegeben hat.
Die CVP hat stets betont,
dass sie im Wahljahr 2019
ganz auf den digitalen Kanal setzt.
Die Partei
macht auf Google Wahlwerbung
mit Politikerinnen und Politikern
der Konkurrenz.
Die Reaktionen kamen schnell.
Innert kurzer Zeit
wurde der Hashtag #cvpfail
zum meistgetwitterten Schlagwort
der Schweiz.
Gianna Luzio am Tag nach dem Sturm.
Unzählige Anrufe hat sie gestern
zur CVP-Google-Kampagne erhalten.
Jetzt trifft sie sich
mit Martin Künzi zur Nachbesprechung.
Er ist Chef von Enigma,
der Digitalagentur,
welche die Kampagne umgesetzt hat.
Dass wir
so viel Aufmerksamkeit generieren,
hat sicher den einen oder die andere
unter uns überrascht.
Und die viele
negative Aufmerksamkeit?
Es ist Aufmerksamkeit.
Gestern lief ziemlich viel.
- Es lief ziemlich viel.
Ich bin in einem Unternehmerforum.
Einer hat mir geschrieben:
"Hätte ich der CVP nicht zugetraut.
Ziemlich geile Guerilla-Aktion."
Das sind Leute, die nicht
im politischen Umfeld sind.
Du wirst jetzt natürlich ...
Alle verwerfen die Hände und so.
Aber die Leute, die es von aussen
sehen, haben eine andere Färbung.
Das ist das Einzige, das ich ...
Ich muss den Anruf entgegennehmen.
- Klar.
Hallo.
Damit muss man leben, wenn man
eine solche Kampagne lanciert.
Als wir das vor einem Jahr mit
der Parteileitung angeschaut haben,
haben wir gesagt:
"Wenn wir das machen,
wird das laut."
Die Aktion provoziert. Sie
ist vielleicht nicht CVP-typisch.
Aber die Schwierigkeit der CVP
ist ja,
dass sie eine Mittepartei ist,
die nicht provozieren kann.
Daher ist es auffällig,
wenn die CVP so was macht.
Das ist nicht so typisch,
aber es tut der CVP gut,
zu sagen: "Wir sind nicht so brav,
wie wir scheinen."
Am gleichen Morgen bei der FDP.
Hier hat die CVP-Kampagne
für Ärger gesorgt.
Dass etwas kommt, wussten wir schon.
Gianna Luzio hat das vor ungefähr
zwei Wochen in der Zeitung gesagt.
Wir wussten nicht genau, was kommt.
Aber schon da
läuteten bei mir die Alarmglocken.
Sie sagte, die CVP komme
mit nicht CVP-gebrandeten Webseiten.
Warum steht eine Partei
nicht mit ihrem Namen hin?
Das ist für mich
ein absolutes No-Go.
Es ist eine Spirale,
die angetrieben wird.
Wie weit darf man gehen?
Wie weit geht der Nächste?
Ich habe ein Problem damit.
Und ich habe ein Problem damit,
das von einer Partei zu hören
oder angestossen zu bekommen,
die der Meinung ist,
sie halte die Schweiz zusammen.
Ja. Machen wir weiter.
Auf dem CVP-Generalsekretariat
versucht man derweil einzuschätzen,
wie sich der Aufruhr um die Kampagne
in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen
auswirken wird.
In zwei Wochen
wird das schon ganz anders bewertet.
Und auf Twitter ist es nur die FDP.
Die SVP
interessiert das sowieso nicht.
Für die ist das normal.
Auch von der SP kommt relativ wenig.
Es ist nur die FDP.
Es ist spannend zu sehen,
wie ihnen dieser Spin gelungen ist.
Gestern haben sie
grosse Empörung generiert,
die uns sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit,
aber auch viel Gegenwind gab.
Wir als Partei
sind es uns nicht so gewohnt,
mit Überzeugung
im Gegenwind zu stehen.
Daran müssen wir
in den nächsten Tagen arbeiten.
V.a. in der Romandie ...
Michael, wir müssen uns nachher
noch ein paar Überlegungen machen
und ein paar Telefongespräche führen
und Mails schreiben,
um die Reihen wieder zu schliessen.
Es ist intensiv.
Und es ist, ehrlich gesagt,
auch nicht immer lustig.
Es ist ... Es dreht einfach
und dreht und dreht und dreht.
Ich sage mir immer:
Um diesen Job gut zu machen,
brauche ich ein wenig Distanz.
Ich brauche Abstand und Platz,
um mir Gedanken zu machen.
Das fehlt im Moment sicher.
Am Tag der nationalen Klimademo
in Bern
macht Anna Gallati in Luzern
Basiswahlkampf für die SP.
Wir versuchen,
unsere Leute zu motivieren.
Wir wollen sie an der Stange halten
mit Bananen und Gipfeli.
Für die erste grosse
Schlussmobilisierung vor den Wahlen
erwartet Gallati
mehrere Dutzend Parteimitglieder.
Wo du dich wohlfühlst ...
Deren Job: telefonieren.
Wir haben viele Leute, die es schon
gemacht haben. Aber auch viele neue.
Fühl dich frei, zu fragen,
wenn etwas ist.
Hinter dir ist das WLAN-Passwort.
- Ja, gut.
Es reicht nicht mehr, nur zu wählen.
Ich fand, ich muss mehr machen
als nur wählen und abstimmen.
Die SPler rufen Leute an,
die in irgendeiner Form schon mal
mit der Partei zu tun hatten
und ihre Nummer hinterlassen haben.
Ein streng gehüteter Datensatz,
der hier genutzt wird.
Grüezi, hier ist Judith Dörflinger
von der SP Luzern.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen über die Wahlen
vom 20. Oktober sprechen.
Gehen Sie wählen? Sie haben schon?
Das Beste, was Sie für uns tun
könnten, wäre die SP-Liste ...
Ah, okay, Sie haben schon gewählt,
aber nicht für die SP.
Danke gleichfalls.
Merci, tschüss.
Es ist extrem, niemand geht ran.
Anna, tu etwas!
Zur gleichen Zeit bereitet sich
Florence Brenzikofer in Bern
auf die Klimademo vor.
80'000 Leute
erwarten die Organisatoren.
Für Brenzikofer der
vorläufige Höhepunkt des Wahljahrs.
Kleines Gruppenfoto.
(Alle) Plus chaud, plus chaud,
plus chaud que le climat.
Plus chaud, plus chaud,
Zurück in Luzern bei der SP.
Wir haben uns überlegt,
ob es sinnvoll ist,
einen Telefonsamstag zu machen.
Die Entscheidung lag dann bei uns
und wir fanden, es braucht beides.
Es braucht Leute auf der Strasse.
Es gibt aber auch solche, die
nicht gerne auf die Strasse gehen.
Für eine konsequente Klimapolitik
brauchen wir einen Linksrutsch.
Davon bin ich überzeugt.
Und wir versuchen ,
unseren Teil dazu beizutragen.
Für den Linksrutsch
und für die Klimapolitik,
die sich verändern muss.
Heizt du mit den Texten ein?
On est plus chaud, on es plus chaud,
on est plus chaud que le climat.
Das haben die Welschen.
Eine der grössten Demonstrationen,
die es in Bern je gegeben hat,
kündigt an: Die grüne Welle
wird bis zu den Wahlen weiterrollen.
(Alle) Rauf mit den Klimazielen,
runter mit dem CO2.
Rauf mit den Klimazielen,
Thank you very much for your words.
Es ist grossartig,
was hier passiert.
Ich selbst wurde auch
durch eine Welle politisiert,
die Frauenwelle in den 90er-Jahren.
Damals war ich auch
auf dem Bundesplatz.
Damals wurde eine Bundesrätin nicht
gewählt, die mich politisiert hat.
Was heute hier passiert,
ist sehr berührend.
Derweil in Luzern bei der SP.
Sie war wütend, denn sie sagte,
sie wähle seit Jahren die Grünen
und habe uns das auch schon gesagt.
Wir sollen sie nicht mehr anrufen.
Entschuldigung.
Wenn du ...
- Das macht gar nichts.
Du kannst diese Leute
auch mit mir verbinden.
Dann kann ich es erklären.
- Perfekt.
Das darfst du
nicht persönlich nehmen.
Kein Ding.
Solche Nummern würden blockiert,
sagt Anna Gallati.
Und wer angerufen werde,
habe Anrecht auf volle Transparenz,
woher die Partei die Nummer hat.
560 Anrufe
sind das Tagesziel der SP Luzern.
Gallati
ist mit dem Zwischenstand zufrieden.
Der SP Luzern
geht es so gut wie noch nie:
historischer Rekordstand
an Mitgliedern und Wählern
dank Basiskampagnen
auf kommunaler und kantonaler Ebene.
Nun könnte gar ein zweiter
Nationalratssitz drinliegen.
Nur damit ihr wisst, wie viele
Gespräche heute schon geführt wurden
und wie es gelaufen ist.
Nebst diesem Anlass sind noch sieben
Personen am Telefon in Emmenbrücke
und drei in Sursee.
Mit ihnen gemeinsam hatten wir knapp
300 Gespräche bis heute Mittag.
Mega cool.
Den Sitz haben wir also?
- Den haben wir gewonnen.
Wir können den Champagner öffnen.
Wenn wir so weitermachen.
Die Kanti Kreuzlingen hat Diana
Gutjahr zu einem Hearing eingeladen.
Mit auf dem Podium:
SP-Ständeratskandidatin
Nina Schläfli.
Gefragt ist dann aber v.a. Gutjahr.
Was ist Ihre Meinung
zur gleichgeschlechtlichen Ehe
und zum Adoptionsrecht?
Dazu vertrete ich nicht
die Parteimeinung.
Jeder soll sein Leben so leben,
wie es für ihn stimmt.
Wer kann behaupten,
dass zwei Frauen oder zwei Männer,
die ein Kind adoptieren möchten,
nicht gleich gute Eltern sein können
wie ein Mann und eine Frau?
Sie kennen sich
in der Wirtschaft aus.
Würden Sie etwas in der Industrie
ändern, um die Umwelt zu schützen?
Oder ist es Ihnen nicht so wichtig?
Es ist absolut wichtig.
Es braucht beides.
Aber in gesundem Mass.
Man muss aufpassen, dass man nicht
immer einem Hype hinterherrennt
und dafür anderes ausblendet.
Habe ich das richtig verstanden,
haben Sie den Klimawandel
soeben als Hype,
als Trend bezeichnet?
Ja, denn es ist
von 0 auf 100 gegangen.
Es hat ...
Es ist ... Werbetechnisch
hat man das sehr klug gemacht.
Es gab ein junges Mädchen -
ich erwähne den Namen nicht,
Sie alle wissen,
von wem ich sprechen.
Nichtsdestotrotz,
man muss darüber sprechen,
aber man darf es nicht
ins Extreme treiben,
sonst gibt es keine Lösungen.
Die Politik macht nicht die Umwelt,
der Mensch macht die Umwelt.
Mit Gegenwind hat Diana Gutjahr
bei den Gymnasiasten gerechnet.
Von der Heftigkeit
wurde sie allerdings überrascht.
Ich habe 2 Std. geredet.
Wenn sie 10 Min. geredet hat,
abgesehen von der Einführung,
war das schon viel.
Wusste die andere nichts?
- Was gewusst?
Die Fragen gingen alle an mich.
- Eben ...
Das ist, weil du
aus dem Betrieb kommst und weisst,
wie hart es in unserer Industrie
zu und her geht.
Dann kommen natürlich die Fragen,
ist doch völlig klar.
Nein, es war immer dasselbe -
Klima, Klima, Klima.
Nur diese Frage?
Wobei, was mich erstaunt hat:
Es waren ja vier Gruppen ...
In der ersten Gruppe
war das Klima kein Thema.
Dann fingen sie an mit Klima und ...
... Homosexuellen.
- So ein Blödsinn.
Ist das unser grösstes Problem
in der Schweiz?
Dann geht es uns aber gut, nicht?
Ist doch unglaublich.
Und dass jeder morgens zur Arbeit
muss und eine Stelle braucht,
ist einfach selbstverständlich?
Es war anstrengend.
Gianna Luzio arbeitet im Moment
sieben Tage die Woche.
Es ist Session. Die letzte,
bevor die Karten neu gemischt werden.
Salut, Michael.
J'ai perdu mon president mais ...
Je vais le retrouver.
Jetzt den Kopf noch
fürs Kerngeschäft frei zu haben,
also Gesetze zu beschliessen,
ist schwierig.
So kurz vor den Wahlen
sind alle sehr, sehr, sehr nervös.
Wie zeigt sich das?
Es zeigt sich so ...
Viele sagen: "Warum machst du
das nicht? Warum das noch nicht?"
Man vergisst, dass man
gewisse Dinge entschieden hat.
Ich schaue nur, wann ich
zur Abstimmung gehen muss.
Man kommt unter Druck. Alle machen
sich Sorgen um ihr Wahlresultat.
Sie sind nervös.
Es muss alles
noch mal schneller gehen,
man muss noch mehr
mit den Leuten reden.
Das ist sehr intensiv.
Am Ende der Legislaturperiode
müssen auch viele Geschäfte
zu Ende gebracht werden,
das ist schwierig.
Sie ist die einzige,
die immer Ruhe behält. Die einzige.
Sie hat noch nie die Nerven
verloren, das muss man sagen.
Gut ...
Eine andere persönliche Erfahrung.
Nach der Session hängt Gianna Luzio
noch einmal 10 Std. Arbeit an.
Sie fährt nach Chur und zurück.
Luzio kandidiert im Kanton Graubünden
für den Nationalrat -
als Listenfüllerin.
Das alles zusammen
ist am Limit des Machbaren.
Ich lerne sehr viel
über mich selbst.
Was lernt man dabei?
Sich etwas zuzutrauen.
Glaube ich.
Wenn ich auf das letzte Jahr
zurückblicke,
ist es v.a. das -
mir etwas zuzutrauen.
Dass es klappt.
Ist dieser Job etwas,
das man dauerhaft machen kann?
Oder kann man das
nur alle vier Jahre mal leisten?
Ich möchte das
nicht dauerhaft machen.
Sonst könnte ich es
nicht mehr gut machen.
Denn es ist etwas,
das sehr viel von einem verlangt.
Es zehrt an meinen Kräften,
an mir als Mensch.
Es bringt mich zwar auch weiter,
aber es zehrt an mir.
Nein, ich will nicht 20 Jahre lang
so weitermachen wie im letzten Jahr.
Herzlich willkommen zum letzten
"Wahlbarometer" vor den Wahlen.
Es könnte sich
für Schweizer Verhältnisse
im Nationalrat einiges bewegen.
In der Grafik wird klar:
Gewinner gibt es nur zwei.
Die Grünen und die Grünliberalen.
Die FDP, im Gegensatz zur
letzten Umfrage, verliert wieder.
FDP-Kampagnenleiter Matthias Leitner
weiss noch nicht, was ihn erwartet.
Er erhält das Wahlbarometer
in diesem Moment.
Minus 1,2.
Das ist viel.
Aber es ist ...
Wir müssen ...
* Handy *
Sorry.
Ciao, Marcel.
Wir müssen erst mal schauen.
Wir müssen es erst mal lesen.
Gut, ciao. Tschüss.
Wahlkampfteam.
FDP-Generalsekretär Samuel Lanz
kommt zur Lagebesprechung.
Wollen wir es von vorne durchgehen?
Das müssen wir nicht diskutieren.
- Nein.
Mich erstaunt, dass wir keine
Indizien auf nationaler Ebene haben,
sei es über Bürgerbriefe,
über Feedback aus den Kantonen,
über Kandidaten oder sonst etwas,
dass es eine so grosse Abwanderung
in Richtung SVP gibt.
Also, letztlich
muss die Botschaft sein:
Der Kampf beginnt jetzt.
Er ist nicht fertig.
Ich frage mich aber doch ...
Was können wir sonst noch machen?
Gibt es die Chance ...
"20 Minuten".
Oder die Sonntagszeitungen.
"20 Minuten"
wäre natürlich insofern ...
... ein Zeichen,
dass wir noch mal Gas geben.
Marcel soll das abklären.
Und ich schaue in der Kasse nach, ob
wir noch ein Krümelchen Geld haben.
* Handy *
Bis später.
Zwei Tage später
platziert die FDP ein Inserat
auf der Frontseite von "20 Minuten" -
für knapp 200'000 Fr.
Etwa 80'000 Fr. haben Gutjahrs
in den Wahlkampf investiert.
Und viel Zeit.
Ihre Wähler mobilisiert Gutjahr heute
in der hintersten Ecke
des Kantons Thurgau:
am Herbstmarkt in Fischingen.
Muss ich Sie wählen?
- Das wäre natürlich schön.
Ich würde mich freuen.
Für Sie auch noch etwas.
Am Sonntag ist es so weit,
noch eine Woche.
Alles klar, schönen Nachmittag.
Wäre das nichts - meine Tochter?
Ich habe sie sogar mitgenommen.
Das gebe ich Ihnen,
damit Sie dran denken.
Sie ist SVP?
- Ja.
Ich.
Seit wann sind Sie in Bern?
- Seit zwei Jahren.
Zwei Jahre?
- Vor vier Jahren kandidierte ich.
Vor zwei Jahren rutschte ich
für Hansjörg Walter nach.
Darf ich euch einen Tipp geben?
Meine Tochter.
Wir haben schon gewählt.
Diana habe ich auch gewählt.
Hier steht sie!
- Ach so?
Ja!
Gehen Sie wählen? Ade.
Jetzt kommt noch Tanja Neujahr.
Äh, Gutjahr!
Mit ihr habe ich Duzis gemacht.
Hör mal, Tanja ...
Diana -
wenn wir schon beim Namen sind.
Diana, nicht Tanja.
Ich habe die Liste genommen,
habe noch Kurt Egger
aus dem Hinterthurgau draufgesetzt,
aber sonst seid ihr voll dabei.
# Höch oben am Berg müesst's si,
# mitte im Sunneschi,
# im grüene Chlee.
* Jauchzen *
Kommt alle, auf Tanja!
Diana!
- Diana!
Oh!
So, das wäre die erste Beiz,
Houdini.
So läuft die Schlussmobilisierung
bei der SP.
Beizentour in der Luzerner
Innenstadt, zwei Tage vor den Wahlen.
Hast du es schon gemacht?
- Schon gemacht.
Habt ihr uns auch unterstützt?
Na ja, ich habe die Grünen gewählt.
- Auch gut.
Morgen kann du noch wählen.
Du musst es einfach vorbeibringen.
Wenn ihr es noch nicht gemacht hat,
dann wäre es toll. Super.
Gallatis Kampagnenjob ist beendet.
Trotzdem ist sie noch für
die Partei unterwegs - freiwillig.
Wir haben mal den Sitz
um 200 Stimmen verpasst.
Es kommt wirklich
auf jede Stimme an.
Hallo, schon gewählt?
Hallo, Hasan.
Schau mal, Ariane.
- Wo ist sie?
Oh ja, die Jungen.
Hallo.
Habt ihr schon gewählt?
- Ja, die SP.
Wirklich? Gut.
Darf ich euch
beim Weintrinken stören?
Am Sonntag sind Wahlen, vielleicht
habt ihr schon alles erledigt.
Falls nicht,
habt ihr noch zwei Tage Zeit.
Habt ihr schon gewählt?
Es liegt verschlossen zu Hause.
- Yes.
Hoi, Yannick.
Dieser Moment, der kommt,
dieses Loslassen ...
Jetzt kann man nichts mehr machen.
Und am Sonntagabend
fühlst du dich leer.
Wir können nur hoffen, dass es
gut läuft. Hast du ein gutes Gefühl?
Ich weiss nicht so recht.
Doch, doch! In meiner Bubble fühlt
es sich an, als würde es gut laufen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Vielen Dank.
Ich bin gestern um 22 Uhr ins Bett
und habe durchgeschlafen bis 8 Uhr.
Ich weiss nicht,
wann ich das letzte Mal
so tief und lange geschlafen habe.
Das war gut.
Du isst auch?
Die letzten drei Wochen waren übel.
Immer wieder geträumt von Wahlen
oder irgendwelchen Massnahmen.
Irgendwas Merkwürdiges.
Aber ich hatte immer wieder mal eine
Nacht, in der es einigermassen ging.
Gut?
- Ja.
Herzlich willkommen.
Heute sind Wahlen.
Ich führe euch durch
das Generalsekretariat der FDP.
Ein kleiner Einblick,
wie wir uns organisieren. Kommt mit!
Wahlkampfchef
und Social-Media-Moderator in einem:
FDP-Mann Matthias Leitner
hat auch am Wahltag volles Programm.
Wenn ihr up to date bleiben wollt:
fdp.ch und auf unseren
sozialen Kanälen. Be there!
Doch eigentlich
ist ihm nicht zum Lachen zumute.
Aus den Kantonen
gibt es erste schlechte Nachrichten.
Zuberbühler gewählt,
Abderhalden nicht gewählt.
Um 150 Stimmen.
160 Stimmen.
Knappe Resultate
sind ein Teil der Demokratie.
Es kackt mich etwas an. Sorry.
CVP-Generalsekrärin Gianna Luzio
ist auf das Schlimmste vorbereitet.
Sich gegen aussen nichts
anmerken lassen, lautet die Devise.
Lief es gut bis jetzt?
- Ich glaube schon.
Gerry, setz dich doch in die Mitte.
Dann können wir rundherum sitzen.
Kurz vor 15 Uhr
erste Lagebesprechung im Bundeshaus.
Was man jetzt sagen kann,
besser als vor 1 Std.,
als wir es
noch weniger genau wussten:
Es ist absehbar,
dass wir in der Deutschschweiz
in der Tendenz weniger verlieren,
als in jeder Umfrage
vorausgesagt wurde.
Diese Aussage kann man machen.
- Ist es stabil?
Es ist in den meisten Kantonen
nicht instabil.
Das befürchtete Debakel
scheint fürs Erste abgewendet.
Jetzt dauert es nicht mehr lange.
Hallo.
Im Baselbiet
gibt es erste Hinweise darauf,
dass die Grünen an diesem Tag
alle Erwartungen übertreffen werden.
Florence Brenzikofer ist mit
Freundinnen unterwegs nach Liestal.
An den eigenen Sitz
wagt sie noch nicht zu glauben.
Es sieht gut aus,
aber ich kann noch nicht viel sagen.
Basel-Stadt sieht sehr gut aus.
Wir machen den Sitz.
Und in Baselland sind die grossen
Gemeinden noch nicht ausgezählt.
Viel Glück.
- Danke.
Auch die Luzerner SP macht sich
bereit für einen langen Wahltag.
Die ersten Neuigkeiten:
vermeintlich gut.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Hoffen wir, dass es so bleibt.
Wir gewinnen den Sitz.
Habt ihr die letzten Zahlen gesehen?
Ja.
- Nein.
Im Moment sieht es so aus,
als würden wir den verdammten
zweiten fucking Sitz machen.
So geil!
Nur schon, dass ...
Wir können jetzt etwas feiern.
- Jetzt müssen wir feiern.
Zum Wohl!
Bei Diana Gutjahr im Thurgau.
Auch hier: vorerst gute Neuigkeiten.
Bei den Auslandschweizern,
Warth-Weiningen, sieht gut aus.
Bettwiesen, die meisten Stimmen.
Wahlkampfleiter Roland Gutjahr
führt Buch.
Wir müssen schauen, was wir
noch alles zusammenkriegen.
Sevi holt alle Listen,
dann haken wir alles ab.
Dann sehen wir,
ob wir auf Kurs sind.
Er hat wieder zwei.
Ach, diese Spannung!
Ich weiss schon, warum ich
ein weisses Hemd angezogen habe.
Man sieht nicht, wie ich schwitze.
Florence Brenzikofer
kommt im Rathaus an.
Hallo, wie geht's?
- Gut.
Ich bin froh, dass es vorbei ist.
Du wahrscheinlich auch.
Vielleicht dauert es noch
bis zum 24. November.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Langsam kannst du dich damit
befassen, Nationalrätin zu sein.
Wir warten erst mal die Zahlen ab.
Ja, warten wir noch auf die Zahlen.
Aber es sieht gut aus.
Das habe ich gestern schon gesagt.
Im zweiten Wahlgang
gibt es einen Kampf
zwischen Daniela Schneeberger
und Maya Graf.
Zwei Frauen liegen vorne,
das freut mich.
Es dauert noch einen Moment.
Oder Maya Graf wird es schaffen
und du wirst
die erste Nachrückende sein.
Wir sehen es,
wenn alle Gemeinden ausgezählt sind.
Wie viele Gemeinden sind ausgezählt?
Immer noch 68.
Hier ist
die erste nationale Hochrechnung
der eidgenössischen Wahlen 2019.
Man könnte fast sagen,
es handle ich um grünen Monsun.
Die SVP verliert 3,1 %.
Die SP verliert 2,3 %.
Die FPD verliert 1,2 %.
Die CVP legt leicht zu,
kommt insgesamt auf 12,0 %.
12 %?
- Das kann gar nicht sein.
- Sagen sie.
Wir schauen mal,
es ist noch nicht Abend.
Wir machen eins nach dem anderen.
Vergesst nicht, heute Morgen
haben wir gesagt, 2 % fehlen uns.
Bleiben wir cool!
Wir rechnen damit, selbst
wenn wir die Prozente halten können,
dass wir Sitze verlieren.
Tessin ist ...
- ... noch nicht weg.
Aber wir rechnen damit.
Und Waadt ist weg.
Das sind fünf.
- Zwei gewonnen, Aargau, Uri.
Dann sind wir bei minus drei.
Nur minus drei?
Hallo.
Ich muss die Zahlen sehen,
bevor ich die Botschaft sehe.
Aber letztlich lohnt es sich nicht,
die ...
Es wird eine Niederlage geben, und
es lohnt sich nicht, das zu leugnen.
Die ist da
und man muss selbstkritisch sein.
Die Frage ist,
wie es interpretiert wird,
und da gibt es
nicht nur eine Wahrheit.
Der Wahltag geht dem Höhepunkt
entgegen: Elefantenrunde.
Er muss zum Mikrofon.
- Toi, toi, toi.
* Spannungsvolle Musik *
(Video) FPD-Chefin Petra Gössi
und Regula Rytz von den Grünen,
die heutige Siegerin.
Eine unglaublich starke
Verschiebung.
Man hat es vorausgesehen,
aber nicht in dieser Dimension.
Fast schon ein Erdrutschsieg.
Es bleibt sehr oberflächlich.
Diese Diskussionen
sollten mehr in die Tiefe gehen.
Die CVP bleibt stabil, doch Gerhard
Pfister ist immer noch vorsichtig.
* Spannungsvolle Musik *
Gerry, ein kleines Update.
Wir sind im Moment
bei nur minus zwei Sitzen.
Du darfst noch etwas entspannter
und positiver werden.
Gut?
War ich zu wenig entspannt?
- Dein Blick war etwas grimmig.
Herr Pfister, können wir
noch ein Gruppenbild machen?
Nein, nein.
Komm, Gerry, sonst ist
die Rytz drauf und du nicht.
Könnt ihr das nicht planen?
Direkt zu mir in die Kamera blicken!
Die Freude kommt
je länger desto mehr.
Aber wir sind so ... Wir haben
so stark darauf hingearbeitet,
mit den anderen Szenarien
gut umgehen zu können.
Es braucht in allen Köpfen
und Bäuchen und Herzen
noch einen Moment,
bis wir es realisieren.
Frauenfeld:
Diana Gutjahr verfolgt die Verluste
der SVP in der übrigen Schweiz.
Oh, Mann!
Jetzt sieht man,
wer abgewählt wurde.
Thomas Müller
hat es nicht mehr geschafft.
Barbara Keller nicht mehr geschafft.
Nur noch vier Sitze.
Auf diesen Moment
haben wir lange gewartet.
Ich darf Ihnen sagen,
von der SVP gewählt sind
die beide bisherigen Frauen,
Diana Gutjahr und Verena Herzog.
Super gemacht. Tipptopp.
Gutjahr schafft die Wiederwahl -
mit dem besten Resultat
im Kanton Thurgau.
Am Ende ist es ein total ...
Man kann nicht sagen,
was den Ausschlag gegeben hat,
aber wenn ich zurückblicke:
Die letzten zwei Jahre und
der Wahlkampf haben sich gelohnt.
Ich bin glücklich über den heutigen
Tag, dass wir das erreicht haben.
Florence Brenzikofer
kennt ihr Resultat noch nicht.
Ich weiss es noch nicht.
16'000 Stimmen, gratuliere.
Zweiter Platz bei den Grünen
im Kanton Baselland.
Und Maya Graf steht im zweiten
Wahlgang für den Ständerat,
als klare Favoritin.
Florence Brenzikofers Einzug in den
Nationalrat ist so gut wie sicher.
Grossartig.
Ich freue mich extrem
und bin sehr glücklich.
Das war ja nicht nur
eine One-Woman-Arbeit,
es freut mich also besonders
für das ganze Team.
Ihre Arbeit wird honoriert.
... dass sie Chancen hat.
Florence Brenzikofer hat heute
Oltingen mit ihrem Resultat
von der zweitgrünsten zur grünsten
Gemeinde der Schweiz gemacht.
Hallo!
- Hoi.
Enttäuschung bei Anna Gallati:
Aus dem zweiten Luzerner
SP-Nationalratssitz wird nichts.
Wir können mit dem Resultat
zufrieden sein.
Es hat um 280 Listenstimmen nicht
gereicht für einen zweiten Sitz.
Für dieses Ergebnis haben sehr viele
Leute, habt ihr alle gearbeitet.
Ihr habt enorme Arbeit geleistet.
Vielen Dank an alle,
die für uns auf die Strasse sind,
die ihr Gesicht hergegeben haben
und für die Sozialdemokratie
eingestanden sind. Vielen Dank.
* Pfiffe, Jubel *
Es hat sich gelohnt,
all diese Stunden.
Hier hinten stehen Menschen ...
Wir haben insgesamt
über 1'500 Freiwilligenstunden
von Mitgliedern,
die beim Telefonieren oder
bei Quartierumfragen geholfen haben.
Ohne das wäre dieses Resultat
nicht möglich gewesen.
Ich bin mega glücklich.
Aber als Linke tut es auch weh.
C'est la vie.
Voila. Ist das das Bild,
das man abgeben will?
* Lachen *
Also, viva!
Auch bei der FDP
will keine Feierlaune aufkommen.
Die Chefin
kommt irgendwann noch vorbei.
Zum Wohl.
Für mich war das sozusagen
der Höhepunkt meiner Karriere hier.
Ich werde sehen,
wohin es mich verschlägt.
Ich würde ihn am liebsten
hier anketten.
Nein, nein!
Der beste operative
Wahlkampfleiter ever.
Danke dir.
Ich bin gekommen, um euch
ein herzliches Dankeschön zu sagen
für den Supereinsatz,
den ihr geleistet habt.
Jetzt feiert noch schön! Ihr könnt
auch erst morgen Abend aufräumen.
Für Gianna Luzio
ist der Wahltag beendet.
Und mit ihm ihr erstes Jahr
als Generalsekretärin der CVP.
Genau, genau.
Dürfen wir hier raus?
Ja, ich höre dich noch.
Zürich und Waadt,
wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe.
Genau, und St. Gallen.
Dann haben wir noch zwei gewonnen.